what did you what have you announced
today this big initiative which seems to
be the first of its kind
it is indeed and we're very happy and
proud about it we announced that pfizer
will provide all
the patent-protected medicines those
that are not available with chip
generics to all low-income countries and
in addition to that to all the global
countries that graduated from that
status 10 years ago that's a total of 45
countries 1.2 billion of people
at cost
and not only that we will provide all
the medicines that we have now but we
are making the commitment that all the
future medicines and typically we are
bringing one to new medicines that we
are discovering every year that will be
included automatically in this accord
how have you been able to make this
happen how bluntly can you afford to do
it we know developing new medicines
costs an enormous amount of money and
time how have you been able to make this
happen
i think that the money was not the issue
i think it was a lot of technical and
bureaucratic issues that had to be
resolved with how to ensure the supply
over there the regulatory approval
we can bring the medicines to the people
and these are absolutely the things that
worry me the most rather than the cost
that we will absorb in any case
i think the reason why we did it is
already in 2019 i remember it was the
first
year i took over the first week i took
over me and my new leadership team
we went in a meeting and we said we have
decided what will be the goals of the
next five years
one of them was to reduce by year 2023
by 50
cutting half the number of people in the
world that cannot afford our medicines
and now i think with this announcement
we are making this dream reality
many of your medicines we know from the
kobi vaccine very effective
very welcome
the logistics around that vaccine were
not straightforward because of the new
technologies we're talking about
countries here that do not have advanced
healthcare infrastructure how do you
will you get the medicines from from
fizers to the people who really need
them because if they're in a warehouse
they don't do any good this is a very
big issue and in fact that issue became
very visible during the pandemic
right now there are hundreds of millions
of
doses of our vaccine that are offered
for free not at cost for free including
the shipment and those countries they
have very low vaccination rates they
don't accept any more shipments because
they don't have the infrastructure to do
the vaccinations to
to convince the people to come to do the
to take the vaccines for this reason
in addition to just providing the
medicinal cost we selected five of these
five 45 countries which are
rwanda uganda
ghana malawi and
senegal that we already sign letters
with this governance that we are going
not only to provide the medicines but
work on the ground so to help identify
the blockages the issues because one
thing it is to have a breast cancer
medicine for a woman
but the other thing is that you need to
diagnose that this woman has breast
cancer and one thing is that you are
avoiding to make diagnosis because you
don't have medicines but now you do have
so we need to organize this part as well
the pandemic do you think it is um
so much of this flows from your
learnings with panic do you think the
pandemic has perhaps
reminded the world of the power of
medicine the power of science has it
reminded
your industry of its responsibility to
the whole world rather than just just
those rich countries that are lucky
enough to be able to afford great
medicines i think both are true to a
very high degree i think the world
realized
the value that the vibrant life sciences
sector can bring to society and the life
sciences sector is composed by the
private but also the academia as we saw
the example astrazeneca oxford for
example
so we saw other examples us with biotech
for example that was with a biotech
company and
but also reminded of us when we have
these
weapons in
our
these tools
we must find ways that we
they reach
all and not only those that they can
afford them um can i just quickly ask
you about covid uh
you may well have said this publicly
what are your projections for vaccine
production
for maintaining
control on the pandemic and also the
prospect of new variants and the
requirement to
develop the vaccine i have no concerns
on manufacturing capacity we have built
manufacturing capacity that covers the
needs of the entire world easily right
now and we have perfect our
manufacturing processes now for
clearly we are watching the variants
that are emerging and we we see that
some of them they are smarter than
others and they can evade
to somehow the protection for vaccines
that's why we are working on updated
versions of those vaccines that will
cover those right now we have most of
the data in-house very few remain to to
be collected and then we will present to
regulators like the uk regulator the
european the american regulator all this
information so upgraded and better
vaccines in the future do you have any
idea how many years
we will be administering covert vaccines
do you have a horizon on this i don't
have a crystal ball but there are a lot
of variants that can affect this outcome
but i think the very the virus will
remain among us
and i think we will have the tools to go
back to normal life so i don't think
that because the variants exist we we
have to leave restricts to impose
restrictions on our lives but people who
need to get vaccinated
and then of course there are treatments
the big difference between this year and
last year is that last year we didn't
have that many treatments and if we had
were only for people that were really in
the hospital now we have treatments that
you can take it and don't go to the
hospitals no one should die from covet
nowadays can you believe it three short
years from
chinese flu
i'm gonna pan that into this so quickly
can you believe it i mean you're a man
you know so many things happened and
there was so much in the center of what
was happening i can't believe in other
things okay i may ask you one more maybe
slightly parochial question the uk there
is somewhere around monkey pox i don't
know whether uh smallpox is a vaccine
that advisor has and what you would have
any observations on the outbreaks we are
seeing in europe and america is causing
some concern
clearly like everyone we were alerted
when we see the race of some cases we
didn't have any before and suddenly we
do have
i'm not that worried right now but that
doesn't mean that we just relax we are
watching and monitoring very carefully
looks like this is a situation that is
not that transmittable transmissible so
very difficult to become a pandemic and
also looks like they're already medicine
vaccines that can work now we can debate
if they can work
pretty well or if we need new
generations and this is what exactly we
are doing right now to see if there is a
need so that you can intervene around
so we're staying calm we're staying calm
and monitor i think right now the real
real problem it is really covered
absolutely not now
okay thank you very much